chez chantal bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
fillion alors deux ans plus tard après
tout la ferme - jo après la libération
des 2 michael quel bilan on peut tirer
du passage de dominic barton comme
ambassadeur en chine
mais je pense que le bilan est positif
il avait un mandat relativement limitée
qui consistait à obtenir la libération
des deux michael qui sont maintenant
l'entrée au pays qui sont au canada je
pense qu'en ce sens là c'était sa
principale priorité son mandat a pris
fin ouais alors de toute façon j'ai
l'impression que tout son temps a été
consacré
à cette à cette tension incroyable
maintenant est ce que on pense que la
relation diplomatique la relation
commercial canada chine est en lambeaux
ou est-ce qu'on est entre elles à
reconstruire tranquillement
mais je pense que ça va prendre du temps
parce qu'il ya des torts importants qui
ont été causés à ces relations qui n'ont
jamais été aussi mauvaises depuis des
décennies non seulement c'est dû à
l'arrestation jugée arbitraire au canada
des de michael en chine mais également
ottawa a entrepris au plan international
un ensemble d'initiatives visant à
dénoncer la diplomatie des otages de la
chine la chine n'a pas du tout aimé ils
ont la mémoire un peu dur ils vont pas
pardonner ça au canada donc nettement
est-ce que ce titre là est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il est difficile pour le
canada
de maintenir de construire de rétablir
une relation économique et commerciale
avec la chine mais ça va dépendre du
doigté
diplomatique démontré par ottawa
le canada ne peut pas se passer de la
chine ne peut pas ignorer la chine
monsieur fillion la chine c'est quand
même un pays de 1 milliard 400 millions
d'habitants c'est un pays qui jouit de
relations commerciales économiques
privilégiées avec plus de 130 pays dans
le monde dont davantage que les états
unis c'est également la première
économie mondiale en termes de parité du
pouvoir d'achat
la chine à étaples et la lettre au plan
du pib dans les prochaines années pour
le canada l'idée consiste à trouver un
juste équilibre entre la défense de ces
valeurs copté celle de ses intérêts
juste équilibre dit vous est ce que le
canada peut exercer une forte pression
sur les droits de la personne tout en
développant efficacement ses relations
commerciales
il ya une bonne nouvelle monsieur
fillion la chine ne transformera pas le
canada a le système politique de parti
unique il ya peut-être en ce sens là une
mauvaise nouvelle aussi le canada ne
réussira pas à transformer la chine en
une démocratie d'ici à demain en ce sens
là je pense que le canada devrait
vraiment évaluer la situation et
envisager les bonnes mesures poussant
développement économique la chine pilote
un projet gic est ce que l'initiative de
nouvelle route de la soie c'est un
projet qui vaut plus de 10 fois la
valeur du plan marshall lancé pour la
reconstruction de l'europe après la
deuxième guerre mondiale les entreprises
canadiennes pourraient être importantes
dans la fourniture d'une expertise ou
chercher des poux ce projet mais est il
approprié pour le canada de vouloir
travailler à retisser des liens
commerciaux alors que les
alors que les les droits de la personne
ne sont pas entièrement respectée loin
de là en chine
mais la question monsieur fillion est
plutôt de savoir comment
s'y prendre pour
influencer le cours des choses achille
il n'est pas évident en tant que
puissance moyenne que le canada y
parvient des seuls par exemple au moment
où nous nous parlons vous savez que
l'union européenne a de son côté conclu
il n'ya pas longtemps un gigantesque
accord global d'investissement en chine
en tant que puissance moyenne je pense
que la démarche fou le canada consiste à
ce maître avec les autres démocraties en
occident et dans un dialogue constructif
avec la chine non pas en labo écoutant
mais un engageant un dialogue
constructif pour voir dans quelle mesure
ils pourraient avoir une influence sous
le coup des choses donc vous mais cela
dit le canada est très liée aux
américains aux états unis et donc on
imagine que le canada ne permettra pas
par exemple à huawei de développer la 5g
au canada est ce que le canada va
boycotter diplomatiquement les jeux de
pékin comme l'ont annoncé des états unis
mais cette décision appartient au canada
monsieur fillion se ce qui émerge devant
nous au plan mondial c'est un ordre
mondial multipolaire et à l'intérieur de
cet ordre mondial y aura
vraisemblablement deux autres mondiaux
le piloté par les états unis qui sera un
ordre mondial libéral un autre que
piloté par la chine qui serait un ordre
mondial l'idée à la question pour le
canada consiste à savoir est-ce qu'il va
prendre parti en faveur des états unis
ou contre la chine je pense qu'il ya une
autre option qui est possible celle
suggérée par l'ancien premier ministre
du canada lester b pearson qui a exhorté
le canada a marché sur la scène
internationale au milieu du chemin est
donc à essayer d'être un acteur neutre
et a même constitué un pont dans ce
contexte là entre la chine et les
grandes puissances occidentales c'est un
rôle que le canada a très très bien joué
par le passé on se rappelle que le père
de justin trudeau pierre-elliot trudeau
a été parmi les premiers à reconnaître
que la chine de mao ce qui allait
entraîner la reconnaissance en occident
de plus d'une dizaine de pays il y avait
donc un terme aux narines oui des
discussions en cours entre la chine et
le canada pour la conclusion de deux
deux des changes économique qui pourrait
profiter aux deux pays je pense que le
canada pourrait rompre un peu ce que le
dialogue dans ce sens là et jouer un
rôle d'équilibriste en quelque sorte
chantal huot merci beaucoup
avec les yeux pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit